Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Triangoli che non lo sono più.
Formule di calcolo errate.
Il meccanismo di Antikythera.
Cosa c’entra tutto questo
con la conoscenza?
Da più di vent'anni,
mi occupo di conoscenza
con un mix tra l’organizzazione aziendale,
l’information technology,
e da otto anni anche con l’aiuto
dell’Intelligenza Artificiale.
Tutto questo oggi si chiama
"Knowledge Management".
Dicevo: triangoli, formule e Antikythera.
Se avete le idee un po’ confuse,
iniziamo il percorso.
In realtà, quando parlo di triangoli
non intendo proprio triangoli:
intendo piramidi a sezione triangolare,
che non lo sono più,
perché hanno assunto una sezione
di tipo pentagonale.
La formula di calcolo errata
è tre per otto.
Che, attenzione,
da un punto di vista matematico
continua a fare 24.
Ma da un punto di vista
della conoscenza, no.
Sapete che cos'è questo?
È il meccanismo di Antikythera,
non preoccupatevi se non l’avete
mai incontrato fino adesso.
Però in Grecia ci hanno anche
fatto un francobollo.
Oggi vedremo come
l’Intelligenza Artificiale,
che d’ora in avanti chiamerò
Intelligenza Aumentata -
perché?
Perché dell’argomento
Intelligenza Artificiale
oggi conosciamo solo alcuni strumenti,
che possono essere definiti
Intelligenza Aumentata.
Bene, vedremo come
l’Intelligenza Aumentata
può in qualche modo aiutare
a preservare la conoscenza umana,
a beneficio delle future generazioni.
Da dove partiamo?
Partiamo da un assunto:
tutti quanti sappiamo che, nel tempo,
i processi si modificano.
Ecco, io vi parlerò di un processo
che ho conosciuto da bambino,
perché nella mia famiglia
sono tre generazioni
che nascono tornitori.
E per iniziare questo percorso,
vi parlerò della tornitura.
Un processo che, attenzione,
è stato stabile dall’antichità.
Parlo dalla preistoria,
durante tutta l’epoca romana
fino al Medioevo,
si è tornito praticamente
sempre nello stesso modo.
Poi hanno applicato la forza
dei mulini ad acqua,
e a un certo punto sono
arrivati anche i motori elettrici.
La prima Rivoluzione
Industriale, ovviamente,
ha aiutato notevolmente a modificare;
ma il processo è rimasto
com'era nella preistoria,
è rimasto così fino quasi
agli anni '70 dello scorso secolo.
Oggi, la tornitura è così.
La tornitura si svolge in autonomia,
ciò che viene lavorato
è protetto da uno schermo
e il tornio è governato dal computer.
Una piccola digressione.
Per Albert Einstein, la conoscenza
non è una raccolta di informazioni
su un determinato fenomeno,
ma è basata sull’esperienza concreta
che riusciamo a farci
di un determinato fenomeno.
Ora, in questo periodo,
ma in particolare
da un certo momento in poi,
dagli anni 70 in poi,
cosa è successo?
Che le mani si sono allontanate
dalle cose che venivano lavorate.
Non solo: abbiamo anche nascosto
il processo di tornitura dalla vista.
Ora, un processo che era
stabile dalla preistoria,
a un certo punto è stato sconvolto.
Che cos'è che ha generato
questo sconvolgimento?
L’arrivo della cosiddetta
"Rivoluzione Digitale".
In pratica in quel periodo,
parlo dagli anni 70 in poi,
è successo che tantissimi processi,
che una volta erano solo analogici,
sono diventati digitali.
Questo ha portato a un incremento
della complessità,
e a togliere una parte
dell’esperienza diretta
sui processi, sulle cose da fare.
Il problema è che tutto questo ha generato
un incremento della complessità
della formazione dei nuovi operatori.
Ma vi dirò di più:
fate riferimento al vostro
primo colloquio di lavoro.
La prima volta che siete arrivati
su un posto di lavoro,
e vi hanno chiesto:
"Lei ha l’esperienza di -"
Sapete che spesso e volentieri,
anche oggi nel mondo digitale,
si fa riferimento all’esperienza analogica
dei fenomeni di cui si occupa
un’organizzazione?
Ora,
il fulcro su cui si basa la formazione
delle nuove generazioni,
in realtà fa parte di un argomento
molto più grande.
Si chiama "staffetta generazionale",
che è un patto non scritto
che tutti quanti sottoscrivono,
e tutti devono onorare.
Perché se il patto
che tutti quanti, in qualche modo,
sono chiamati a onorare,
non viene onorato,
cosa succede?
Succede, com’è successo già,
che si interrompe
la staffetta generazionale
di passaggio della conoscenza.
Vedete, queste sono
quattro invenzioni romane
che durante l’epoca medievale
sono andate perse.
Si sapeva che c’era calcestruzzo,
che c’erano le strade romane,
il sistema fognario e gli acquedotti;
ma nessuno sapeva più farlo.
Ecco che arriva
il meccanismo di Antikythera.
Che cos’è il meccanismo di Antikythera?
È un artefatto
che è stato pescato nel 1900
da dei pescatori in Grecia.
Lo hanno ripescato.
Ci abbiamo messo circa
un centinaio d’anni, dal 1900 ad oggi,
per datarlo.
Oggi sappiamo che era del I secolo a.C.
Ma soprattutto, a cosa serviva?
Abbiamo scoperto recentissimamente
che molto probabilmente era un planetario,
in grado di calcolare le eclissi.
Ora, pensate: 2000 anni fa,
esisteva un computer meccanico.
Non è tanto il fatto che per 2000 anni
quell'artefatto è rimasto sott'acqua.
Il problema è che abbiamo perso
la competenza per costruire
quel tipo di meccanismi,
per tantissimi secoli.
Nel tempo, si sono alternate
tre macro fasi economiche.
La prima fase è stata quella del fare,
tipica dell’antichità.
Poi è arrivata l’economia del tempo,
a partire dalla prima
Rivoluzione Industriale.
Oggi siamo nell'economia della conoscenza.
Vorrei farvi riflettere su alcune cose,
sul focus su cui si basava
ogni macro fase,
facendo riferimento al metodo
scelto in ogni fase
per pagare il lavoro delle persone.
Nell’economia del fare,
il problema era produrre le cose.
Non per niente gli operai
venivano pagati a cottimo.
Dalla prima Rivoluzione Industriale
abbiamo iniziato a focalizzare
sul rispetto dei tempi;
e non per niente, ancora oggi,
gli stipendi sono pagati
in base al numero di ore lavorate.
Guardate che nel futuro,
nell’epoca della conoscenza,
inizieremo a pagare le persone
per i contenuti
che hanno saputo costruire.
La costruzione dei contenuti
ha passato varie fasi.
Abbiamo iniziato con la scrittura,
che ha permesso di mettere
in salvo la conoscenza.
La scrittura ha creato le basi
perché a un certo punto potesse arrivare
la cosiddetta digitalizzazione
della conoscenza,
che ha creato le basi,
perché l’Intelligenza Aumentata
potesse entrare in campo.
Occhio però,
perché ci sono voluti 8000 anni
dalla scrittura alla digitalizzazione;
e meno di 70 anni
dall’inizio della digitalizzazione
all'Intelligenza Aumentata.
Ma perché l’Intelligenza Aumentata
può essere vista come uno strumento
per salvare la conoscenza?
Tre esempi,
tre esempi molto semplici.
Gli impianti industriali,
oggi, producono dati.
La conoscenza umana oggi produce testi:
pensate ai libri che sono a disposizione
e tutto quello che è sulle chat,
sui media, sui social media.
La sanità produce tutta una serie di dati
che sono basati sulle analisi,
su tutte le cose che vengono
in qualche modo monitorate
dai monitor sanitari e quant’altro.
Tutti questi sono dati analogici,
che da diverso tempo
sono in corso di trasformazione.
Oggi, tutti quei dati li
stanno diventando digitali.
Una volta nascevano e morivano analogici;
oggi stanno diventando digitali.
Ecco che [arriva]
l’Intelligenza Aumentata,
che ha una capacità:
può studiare dati digitali,
e costruire asset digitali
basati su quei dati.
Ecco: l’Intelligenza Aumentata,
in un certo modo,
è come se stesse trasformando
una parte della nostra esperienza,
anche analogica, in digitale.
Ora, un asset digitale basato
sull'Intelligenza Aumentata,
che cosa può fare?
Oggi conosciamo tre principali tecnologie:
il machine learning;
il deep learning;
e il natural language understanding,
che è una combinazione tra i due.
Per dirla in parole povere,
negli impianti industriali oggi,
grazie all’Intelligenza Aumentata,
può succedere che sia
l’impianto industriale
a proporre dei parametri
di utilizzo agli utilizzatori.
Oppure nella conoscenza umana.
Un esempio - uno, ma guardate
che ce ne sono tantissimi.
Un esempio, uno.
Senza che nessun umano
abbia letto due testi,
l’Intelligenza Aumentata
è in grado di capire
che si parla delle stesse cose.
Può capire il "tono",
cioè le emozioni che sono espresse
all’interno di quei due testi.
In pratica può capire
che sono simili o sono dissimili,
in autonomia.
Nella sanità, siamo in grado
di fare diagnosi precoci.
Oggi, molti di noi potrebbero
essere in questa sala,
grazie all’intervento che c’è stato
della digitalizzazione
di alcuni processi sanitari
che hanno permesso di fare
una diagnosi precoce
di un determinato problema.
Ora, grazie all’Intelligenza Aumentata,
è come se una parte
della nostra conoscenza
venisse messa in sicurezza.
Ritornando all’esempio
che a me è più caro,
perché io provengo da quella famiglia,
parliamo di impianti industriali.
Vi presento Mario.
Mario è un operaio metalmeccanico.
Una volta Mario, che lavorava
su una bellissima fresa manuale,
finito di fare i suoi pezzi conformi,
poteva andare a casa felice.
Ma attenzione:
tutta la conoscenza
su come si facevano i pezzi conformi
rimaneva nella testa di Mario.
Oggi, grazie all’Intelligenza Aumentata,
siamo in grado di studiare
che le scelte fatte da Mario
hanno portato a soluzioni
positive o negative;
e riusciamo a correlare, ad esempio,
che un determinato prodotto,
con una determinata materia prima,
e un certo settaggio della macchina,
e un colpo di martello,
ha prodotto un prezzo conforme.
Altre combinazioni, no.
Altre combinazioni, ulteriormente, sì.
E cosa succede?
Succede che in questo processo
è come se alcuni dati
di processo produttivo
diventassero in qualche modo
una memoria digitale
di quello che è successo in passato,
con l’aiuto di alcune regole statistiche.
Perché dentro l'Intelligenza Aumentata
c'è tantissima statistica.
Risultato?
Vi presento Luigi.
Luigi è un operaio neoassunto.
Vi ricordate quando prima vi ho detto,
al vostro primo colloquio di lavoro,
vi hanno chiesto: ma lei ha esperienza?
È un primo colloquio di lavoro,
probabilmente non ha esperienza,
visto che è il primo.
Oggi Luigi potrebbe essere aiutato
dalla memoria digitale,
creata sulle esperienze di Mario.
Anche se Mario non è più
nell'organizzazione,
in pratica è come
se ci fosse la possibilità
di proporre a Luigi delle soluzioni
che in passato hanno avuto esito positivo,
per cui è possibile dire
che se lavori quel prodotto
con quella materia prima,
e usi questi settaggi.
devi dare un colpo di martello.
Ovviamente Luigi deve sapere
come dare  il colpo di martello,
quindi un po’ di esperienza
dovrà costruirla anche lui.
Però capite perfettamente
che è un passo in avanti notevole.
Introduciamo un aspetto
forse per molti inatteso,
cioè l’impatto della demografia
su tutto questo.
Allora, tutti sappiamo
che in Italia, e in Europa,
ma anche a livello internazionale,
è in corso un calo demografico.
In Italia e in Europa
da vent’anni, trent’anni.
Nelle altre economie,
a livello internazionale
sta succedendo in questo momento,
in alcuni casi per la prima volta.
È un fatto che da tantissimi anni
non raggiungiamo
la soglia di sostituzione,
cioè se ogni donna nella sua vita
non genera almeno 2,2 bambini,
la popolazione di cui
fa parte quella donna
tende a calare.
Alla generazione successiva
non ci sono gli stessi maschi e femmine
che sono stati la generazione precedente.
l’Istat ci dice che
con 400.000 nascite all’anno
siamo destinati, nel giro
di una o due generazioni,
a diventare una popolazione
da 30 milioni di abitanti.
Il Sole 24 Ore ci dice che in 12 anni
il tasso di natalità è calato del 30%,
e siamo terzultimi in Europa.
Ecco che entrano in campo
piramidi e triangoli.
Questo che voi vedete alle mie spalle
è la rappresentazione
della società italiana
suddivisa per classi d’età.
In cima abbiamo i centenari,
in fondo abbiamo quelli
che sono appena nati,
a sinistra i maschi, a destra le femmine.
Sapete qual è il problema,
dietro questo grafico?
Il problema è che una volta
qua si parlava di piramide,
una piramide a sezione triangolare
che è diventata a sezione pentagonale.
E qual è l'impatto di questa cosa?
L’impatto è serissimo,
perché quelli che stanno
andando in pensione,
per la prima volta nella storia
della società italiana,
non sono sostituibili da quelli
della generazione successiva.
Numericamente, mancano persone.
La buona notizia è che i nostri figli
troveranno più facilmente
un posto di lavoro.
Magra consolazione, perché c’è
un altro aspetto molto importante:
che quelli che stanno andando in pensione
sono tutti nativi analogici,
e quelli che invece stanno nascendo oggi
sono tutti quanti nativi digitali.
Ma attenzione:
quelli che stanno andando
adesso in pensione,
sono quelli che si ricordano ancora
come funzionavano le cose
prima di essere digitalizzate.
In molte organizzazioni
che io frequento come consulente,
come esperto di informatica,
o come esperto di Knowledge Management,
mi trovo davanti all’evidenza
che aziende molto digitalizzate,
quando hanno un problema,
vanno a chiedere a chi?
A Mario!
A Mario, che sta per andare in pensione
Perché si ricorda ancora
come le cose funzionavano
quando la digitalizzazione
non aveva preso il passo.
Tre per otto.
Qual è il problema dietro il tre per otto?
In questo momento storico
abbiamo tre generazioni
che condividono la stessa esperienza.
Tutti quanti usano WhatsApp, per dire.
Abbiamo i nativi analogici,
i nativi digitali
e la generazione intermedia.
Ora,
è curioso che dagli anni '70
è iniziata la Rivoluzione Digitale,
e i primi nativi digitali
sono nati trent’anni dopo.
Perché hanno iniziato a nascere dal 2000,
dal 2000 diciamo che sono nativi digitali.
Curioso, no?
Ma c'è un altro aspetto.
Occhio, che abbiamo otto anni.
È la finestra di tempo
che sta dal 2022 al 2030.
Perché otto anni?
Perché il mondo sta migrando
da analogico a digitale,
e in questi otto anni avremo
la compresenza delle tre generazioni.
Ma tra otto anni:
tutti i nativi analogici
saranno in pensione;
inizieranno ad andare in pensione
quelli della generazione intermedia;
e abbiamo un problema.
Dobbiamo focalizzare le nostre energie
per fare sì che i nativi digitali
siano messi in grado
di portare avanti il nostro mondo,
un mondo che sarà digitale.
Dobbiamo dargli strumenti digitali.
Ma quel mondo avrà ancora
degli aspetti analogici.
Ecco che entra in campo
l’Intelligenza Aumentata,
dove in questi tre per otto
può studiare dati digitali,
quelli appunto di Mario,
per dare una mano
con gli asset digitali a Luigi.
Avevo già detto prima che la conoscenza
sta migrando da analogica a digitale.
Tranquilli che siamo arrivati in fondo.
Siamo nell'epoca della conoscenza.
La nostra società ha cambiato forma.
E adesso abbiamo il challenge
del tre per otto,
tre generazioni che devono
collaborare per otto anni.
Siamo nel mezzo
di una delle staffette generazionali
più delicate della storia,
e vi ricordo che nella staffetta
vince sempre il team:
non l’ultimo che passa
il traguardo, l’intero team.
Quindi non saranno i digitali a vincere,
vinceremo tutti quanti.
Anche gli analogici vinceranno.
Lungo lo svolgersi della storia,
l’umanità ha sempre cercato
di preservare le cose belle.
Tocca a noi riscoprire la bellezza
del trapasso delle nozioni.
Perché?
Perché nella staffetta generazionale
insiste la bellezza
della trasmissione della conoscenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)